he is the uh former major league
baseball pitcher cy young winner world
series champ six-time all-star joining
us on behalf of draftkings
cece sabathia back on the program when's
the last time you were called karsten
wow maybe like uh seventh to eighth
grade
i went by carson for a long time in
school and then my friends
you know growing up they just kind of
took over and cece kind of took over
about
like right in high school but then you
have a son so
you have cece the third yeah but he goes
by carsten
so everybody calls for christ everybody
calls him cars
is he gonna change though once he gets
to high school
uh he's in high school so he's a junior
and you know i think just living here in
the northeast um
you know being in yankee land i guess he
it's just easier for him to go by carson
than than cece so
um you know he's he we called him little
c for a long time and he wanted to be
called carsten
uh in about the eighth or ninth grade so
we kind of flip-flop
when's the last time you threw a
baseball oof
um i tried to throw bp to my boys uh
about two weeks ago it didn't it didn't
go too long
i liked it children's still not there
yeah
they took you deep uh i couldn't even
get it there i couldn't even get it
there for them to take me
so it's pretty sad right now if you
watch me throw a baby
did you see the first pitch i threw out
yeah it it's kind of like that
on the regular right well i was
wondering if you were going to be in
front of the mound
you know like i should have you know
what and i i was like should i go to the
front of the mountain because i when i
was pitching i always got
i didn't get mad but just annoyed when
people ran out to the mound you know
what i'm saying like
i'm about to go this is my workspace
but then i like got out there and i went
to the mound and i get on the mountain
i'm like
this is a little too far i'm not going
to make it i knew i wasn't going to make
it immediately
i was wondering like a couple of things
here well walker bueller has problems
with blisters but i don't know do
pitchers get
calluses like a guitar player gets
calluses and then it doesn't
affect you but how does some pitcher why
are they more susceptible to blisters
you know what it's weird you either get
calluses or you get blisters so i was
always a guy that just
i would get like hard skin like calluses
um i can see where guys
like in the same spot where the guys
would get blisters so i can see
how that could affect you and how some
guys you know couldn't pitch with that
and
and it really you know really hurts but
mine would just build up like a hard
really hard callous
you know by like may um i was good to go
for the rest of the season but i can see
how some guys
you know can develop blisters but you
you either get blisters or
it just develops a really hard skin to
kind of turn into a callus so
there's no way around it you kind of get
both but but how do i then
treat a blister if it happens during a
game
is there anything you can put on it do
anything there's really nothing that you
can do
and you know they have like you know
these things that they try like the
liquid you know
skins and all that stuff yeah but it
ends up ripping off you know especially
as soon as you put pine tar on or
you know uh the rosin anything that try
to keep your
your hands sticky um especially in these
playoff games you know what i mean
you're making big pictures
you're sweating your hands get sweaty so
you gotta you gotta have your hand dry
and as soon as you do that
ripping off the ball rips off any kind
of you know any kind of
medicine or anything they put on there
and then you're back raw again so it
it's really tough i watch aj burnett go
through that and
it just sucks man it's really really
tough thing to deal with
what did you think of walker bueller's
pants last night
because you were the baggy ones yeah
yeah
like these are stretch yoga pants he had
on him yeah that's the new age man you
know what i'm saying
everything comes back like the kids now
you know when i was growing up that was
the baggy shorts was the bigger you know
was the was the thing and now
they're going back to like the 70s and
80s my son plays basketball too and
you know the smaller the better these
days everything comes back
i don't know if the smaller the better
the tighter the better though
i can't imagine you out there if you
were pitching now you would be in those
capri pants that walker bueller had on
last night absolutely not
but but but as i got older and you know
some of these younger kids came up they
would give me a lot of crap about how
big my pants were
as you know when i was in the middle of
my career it was cool to wear big pants
so
yeah i mean i i turned into the old you
know not fashioned
not fashionable guy at the end of my
career but you didn't have that at
cleveland when you pitched
the tight pants yeah no baggy pants
um i did uh i started wearing the baggy
pants
about 2004 or five when i deemed myself
a veteran you know old enough to kind of
do whatever i wanted
the first couple years i just wore
whatever they gave me which ended up
being like tight and then i had the
elastic in the
at the bottom so it would bunch up it
was it was a very
uh bad greg maddox look i guess i would
have to say earlier in my career
and you're in cleveland and you're there
at the time lebron is still in high
school i believe
yeah but when did you get word that
there was
this two-way sports star in uh
in the area right away um our
um our trainer with the indians uh
paul spacuzza he left high school
football and basketball games
and he would always tell me about this
kid he was lebron's a freshman at the
time
and he was like you got to come see this
kid play basketball you know he's going
to be
the next michael jordan and he would
always say you know this guy's a great
football player
just come out and see and i'm like
listen i don't like have time to go
watch a 9th grader like a 14 year old go
play like i got other stuff to do you
know what i'm saying
like last thing i want to do is go watch
a 9th grader um
fast forward to the next year he's a
sophomore
um and they're playing the state
championship and it was it was
it was really close and uh paul goes
just come with me to the game
you know what i'm saying it'll be worth
it so i ended up going to me and my wife
and it was it was the lebron james you
see now you know what i'm saying it was
he was a man amongst boys and you know
it was just it was must-see
you know basketball and turned into
must-see tv so you know watching him at
14 15 years old you knew that this is
what he was
you know going to turn into he's cece
sabathia the former cy young winner
world series champion 09 with the
yankees how nervous would you be
if you're a dodger fan given what's at
stake clayton kershaw
today against the braves you know what i
feel pretty good about kershaw going out
there today
um you know he's obviously you know
found his velocities ticked back up um
you know he's found
a way to pitch with the lesser velocity
um you know he's older now and i think
just at some point these things
have to turn around so i would be a
little nervous
but i would actually feel pretty good
about kershaw going out there
considering how he pitched all year this
year and even you know in his last
playoff start until he gave up the
back-to-back homers but
um how much of this is mental though
cece when it comes to playoff baseball
especially with pitchers they're just
some guys like andy pettit
uh curt schilling smoltz they're just
guys that say
you i love the moment give me the ball
and you know good things happen
yeah you know what i can speak to myself
i had to grow into that
because if you look at the way i pitched
in 2007 playoffs
um if i pitch you know the way i pitched
the rest of my career plows
we won the world series in cleveland you
know so i had to kind of grow into
you know wanting the ball and kind of
understanding my body and
you know a lot not letting the moment be
too big so yeah i mean it's one thousand
percent mental when it starts to pile on
and
you know you hear all these different
things and then you know you got your
rival to giants and you got bum
gardner going out there he's dealing
every postseason yeah it starts to play
with your mind but
you know hopefully he can get past this
and he's such a great pitcher i mean
he stopped pitching right now he's going
to the hall of fame so you don't want
this one thing to be a knock so
hopefully he can
pitch these guys to a world series
because if he pitches the way
he pitches in the in the regular season
in the postseason the last five years
they have a title
you know what i'm saying so um you start
to believe it's your fault
what's it like to go out on the mound
and you know you don't have it
it man you know it sounds crazy i never
knew that when i didn't have it
i always i always thought i was like but
you found out though
you did yeah pretty quick but i'm always
like one pitch away
bases loaded i already left seven runs
in the first inning
and you know not a good self-evaluator
in that way to always think that i can
go out and get out
uh even at the end of my career so yeah
i mean
i i always thought i had it do you have
a baseball nearby
um let me see yeah this one right here
yep it is rivera sign baseball
so if you were going to show like a
normal grip like do you know how
kershaw grips like his curveball or
you know does he do anything different
you being both left-handed
yeah no i don't i wish i could uh i wish
i would you know pay attention to that i
looked it up but
when i did throw a curveball it was just
right here on the scene like that
um so you're you're digging your your
nail in the
in the seam i i didn't really dig my
nail in but i kind of like spiked it
okay but i didn't like dig my nail in
like a lot of those guys
just because i i i was always scared
about tipping my pictures so i would
always think like maybe somebody can see
that my nail up or something like that
so
i always wore bigger gloves and like you
know maybe make sure they were really
stiff just so i can
you know hide my change up in there or
be digging around for the ball
and not really you know worry about
somebody seeing what i was grabbing
what did how did mariano hold the ball
for his slider
well was cutter cutter it was it was a
cross like that
and if you threw the same pitch
not the same reaction not the same isn't
that amazing though
yeah you know what so mo and andy really
taught me to cut her which saved me
you know my last four years of my career
um
and and you know i i kind of learned
mo's grip
but i wanted andy's arm action just
because i knew i couldn't ever mimic
what mo was doing with the ball
you know what i mean so i just tried to
get mine as close as to andy pettit as i
could
so i would talk to andy moore about what
he was actually thinking about the
cutter
but i would always use most grip don't
you didn't smear the uh
autograph did you no if i do i can get i
can
what are you doing with draftkings uh so
we teamed up with draftkings through
uh through the playoffs you know just
trying to get people engaged with the
product
i'm a big daily fantasy player so um it
was it was easy and exciting to team up
with them and
you know we team you know throughout the
championship series um
you know we've been you know just doing
interviews and letting people know about
the product
uh do you do fantasy football i do
you almost played college football right
i did yeah so this week was like
the the classic like which you don't
want
as a fantasy player i have pat my homes
but then my raiders were playing kansas
city
and we never beat kansas city in kansas
city it's been 20 years since we beat
kansas city kansas city
so i was a little bummed out that like
we shut them down so much because i
needed to win in fantasy
but i was super excited that that the
raiders got a win in kansas city
so that's kind of like if you're a super
fan of a team
that's kind of like the down that's kind
of like the downside of playing fantasy
you know
uh but you know being a raider fan like
you're okay that they went to vegas
i am um as a fan
you know i grew up a la raider fan
obviously the early 80s
um so you know i wasn't really connect i
mean i'm
super connected to the oakland raiders
being from the bay but but
i traveled to la to go watch them you
know and i have no problem traveling to
vegas uh
as an athlete playing in the oakland
coliseum i'm excited that these guys
have a new place
to play man like oh my god is an
awful awful awful place to play sports
so even to go
watch a game i went to watch a game oh i
went to watch a baseball game there it
was the royals
against the a's and i remember there
were like four guys who came rolling out
of the top deck they were fighting with
each other
there was no fans there whatsoever it
was
that might have been the worst stadium
in all the sports it had to be because
you're not connected
before a baseball game you're so far
away so much foul territory
you know what i'm saying like and as a
as a fan of the raiders you just want
nice stuff like you go to these other
stadiums and you see like nice sweets
and all this stuff and
so now i'm excited to have a brand new
stadium to go to and
you know long as the raiders are the
raiders i'm i'll follow them to the moon
long as they don't change the name
i'll go wherever they go uh are you
doing more media stuff now are you
working with espn or what are you doing
no i did espn that last year yeah that i
played
um now i'm just doing my podcast i have
a podcast with ryan rucco uh
r2c2 uh it's on the ringer and spotify
um and yeah i'm just doing you know
little things like this you should be
doing more
you should be doing some stuff i'm yeah
i'll try you know
right now my son is traveling with
baseball so much and
you know i just didn't want to get on
the schedule where i was like locked
into something
you know every day or every week or
something like that but yeah i mean i
love sports i watch all sports and it
would be fun to
to be able to talk about everything not
just baseball you know um i watch so
much nfl
um nba i watch a lot of soccer so
it'll be fun to have something where i
can just talk all sports all the time
great to talk to you again cece thank
you for joining us and good luck with
draftkings
no problem thanks dan good to see you
that's uh cece sabathia